we didn't talk much about jimmy i mean
he was a critical part of your just
like
of your perseverance through all the
all that you had to go through um what
did you learn from jimmy
what are some impacts that he had on
your life
both on the mat and off the mat
you know
if we had to like
put it down to like a very simple thing
he taught me how to win
right it wasn't necessarily like
the technical side of judo like we went
over gripping we went over this we
adapted that
but the real strength to jimmy was like
he knows how to win
and most people think well if i get
really good at this technique i'll be
able to throw people with it not win
that is not how the world of sports
works
right like i
remember in one of my youtube videos i
was doing a breakdown of a match
from the cuba grand prix where i was
fighting a mongolian guy
he's kicking the [ __ ] at me not gonna
lie
four minutes in like
he was just
throwing me like left and right he was
so fast i felt like i just couldn't get
to him
in the last 30 seconds
he changed he started
protecting his lead
instead of continuing the fight the way
the entire match was going in his favor
he made a mental shift and when he made
that mental shift i beat him yeah
because he didn't know how
to win the fight
he can win exchanges but you can't win
the fight
so the last thing you want to do is have
to
win every exchange in a match
you want to know how to
kick it into sixth gear
like when to step off the gas
when to focus on gripping when to attack
how often to attack all those things
like
and you've had those conversations with
jimmy like this is not like how to stop
trying to win every exchange that kind
of thing yeah and instead because i was
a brawler before i was like if i threw
you once i'm throwing you again yeah and
sometimes you get caught yeah why would
i do that
i'm already winning
what about like the mental side of the
game the preparation all those things
one of the biggest things jimmy brought
to the forefront when it came to like
the mental side was the visualization
right
and when i started visualizing myself
winning i started seeing more success
but once i started seeing more success
with the visualization also came
self-doubt
because as i'm starting to
picture myself like
i would picture myself before fighting
church's philly
i'm gonna throw him with koshigoroma and
i can see it and if i stand in the chute
for too long
you start to like
but what if he counters
then you go well if he counters with
this i'm gonna counter with that but you
already let that doubt in
and then you start playing this like
five step scenario but you still come
out on top but all that doubt has like
seeped into your mind
right and a lot of people don't
understand that
that's a bad thing you're still winning
in your mind but you're also doubting
yourself in your mind yeah once you let
the
like that little sleeping it's just
destructive yeah
and so i remember i was at the world
championship championships i can't
remember what year it was
but i was ready like i was healthy
i was ready to go and we all thought
like this is the year travis wins the
worlds
i go out there in the first round
i'm in the shoot for like 45 minutes
like the match went into golden score
then the next match went into golden
score and the [ __ ] next match went to
golden score then the referee came and
told me you can't weigh your key then
big jim goes why can't he wear his key
any gui that has his name on it we're
not going to let him wear he has to wear
a different key so then i go [ __ ] you
i'm leaving and i walked out there and i
fought i lost in golden score because i
did a cochi and they called it a false
attack and i went
great i'm out of the [ __ ] worlds but
when i was in the shoot
i struggled because
i started allowing the like hungarian
guy that i was gonna face
to do things to me
that i would have to play defense to and
then counter it's like great but now i'm
doubting my own ability so i went to a
sports psychologist and the big game
changer for me was
i focused more on the
emotional physical response that happens
in matches
rather than the actual
you know quote unquote like instagram
picture that would have happened yeah so
when i was getting ready for 2016
you think about
like
how do you feel like standing in the
chute like what does your body feel like
is your heart racing how's your breath
is your mouth dry
and then you think about like okay the
ref just started the match what happens
like how was the atmosphere like how do
you emotionally respond to these things
more so than
me trying to beat a specific judo player
right like oh the ref just gave you a
penalty at a minute 30 like how do you
feel
and then you start thinking about the
physical responses and when you do that
really well
you can actually get the pins and
needles and your body will start to
sweat and your heart will start to race
as if you're in it
because it's not about
the technique it's more about the
physical like what does it feel like to
have your fingers ripped out of a ghee
in the first exchange
now my hands can feel that that's
fascinating and then on a cellular level
like i fought the olympic games so many
times to the point where like it is no
longer a goal it's an anticipation right
so down to the experience of the grip
break the just the sweat the
the heart beating the yeah
does it feel to have your head smashed
into a mat and driven across the mat
with a map burn yeah and then getting
about that yeah and getting back up
yeah like with a bit of a burn all that
kind of stuff the actual sensations in
this case the actual sensation of what
it takes to fight it you don't matter
it's not a strategy like but the actual
sensations yeah experience that's
fascinating
because then your body's going to fight
hundreds of matches without the physical
damage and you could probably get really
far with that and not also in just judo
but basically anything
you can simulate yeah if you learn how
to simulate well
you